so you famously run
barefoot oh do you still run barefoot i
still run barefoot that's so awesome
much to my wife's chagrin
do you want to make an evolutionary
argument for running barefoot is
advantageous um what have you learned
about
human and robot movement in general from
running barefoot
human or robot and or well you know it
happened the other
way right so i was studying walking
robots and
i was there's a great conference called
the dynamic walking
conference where it brings together both
the biomechanics community
and the walking robots community and so
i've been going to this for years and
hearing
talks by people who study barefoot
running and other the mechanics of
running
so i i did eventually read born to run
most people read burned around and then
the other thing i had going for me is
actually that i uh i wouldn't i wasn't a
runner before
and i learned to run after i had learned
about
barefoot running i mean started running
longer distances
so i didn't have to unlearn and i'm
definitely
um i'm a big fan of it for me but i'm
not gonna
i tend to not try to convince other
people there's people who run
beautifully
with shoes on and that's good
but here's why it makes sense for me um
it's all about the long-term game right
so i think it's just too easy to run 10
miles
feel pretty good and then you get home
at night and you realize
uh my knees hurt i did something wrong
right
um if you take your shoes off
then as if you hit hard with your foot
at all
um then it hurts you don't like run 10
miles
and then and then realize you've done
something some damage you have immediate
feedback
telling you that you've done something
that's that's maybe suboptimal and you
change your gait
i mean it's even subconscious if i right
now having run many
miles barefoot if i put a shoe on my
gate changes
in a way that i think is not as good so
so it makes me land softer and i think
my my goals for running are to do it for
as long as i can
into old age um not to win any
races and so for me this is a
you know a way to protect myself yeah i
think um
first of all i've tried running barefoot
many years ago
probably the other way just just just uh
reading born to run but just to
understand because i felt like i
couldn't
put in the miles that i wanted to and it
feels like
running for me and i think for a lot of
people
was one of those activities that we do
often and we never really
try to learn to do correctly like it's
funny there's so many activities
we do every day like brushing our teeth
right i think a lot of us at least me
probably have never deeply studied how
to properly brush my teeth
right or wash as not with a pandemic or
how to properly wash our hands or do it
every day
but we haven't really studied like am i
doing this correctly but running felt
like one of those things
it was absurd not to study how to do
correctly because it's the source of so
much pain
and suffering like i hate running but i
do it
i do it because i hate it but it i feel
good afterwards
but i think it feels like you need to
learn how to do it properly so
that's where barefoot running came in
and then i quickly realized that
my gate was completely wrong i was
taking huge like steps
and uh landing hard on the heel all
those
elements and so yeah from that i
actually learned to take
really small steps look i
already forgot the number but i feel
like it was 180 a minute or something
like that
and i remember i was uh i actually just
took songs that are 180 beats per minute
and then like tried to run at that beat
just to teach myself it took a long time
and i feel like uh
after a while you learn to run you
adjust it properly
without going all the way to barefoot
but i feel like barefoot is the legit
way to do it
i mean i think a lot of people would be
really curious about
it can you if they're interested in
trying what would you
how would you recommend a start or try
or
explore slowly that's the biggest thing
people do is they
are excellent runners and they're used
to running long distances or running
fast and they take their shoes off and
they
hurt themselves instantly trying to do
something that they were used to doing
i i think i lucked out in the sense that
i i couldn't
run very far when i first started trying
and i run with minimal shoes too i mean
i will
you know bring along a pair of actually
like aqua socks or something like this i
can just slip on or
running sandals i've tried all of them
what's the difference between
a minimal shoe and nothing at all what's
like feeling wise what does it feel like
there is i mean i noticed my gait
changing right so
um i mean your your foot has as many
muscles and sensors as your hand does
right sensors oh okay
and uh we do amazing things with our
hands
and we stick our foot in a big solid
shoe right so there's
i think you know when you're barefoot
you're
you're just giving yourself more
proprioception
and that's why you're more aware of some
of the gate flaws and stuff like this
now you have less protection too so
um rocks and stuff i mean yeah so
i think people are who are afraid of
barefoot running that worry about
getting
cuts or getting stepping on rocks first
of all
even if that was a concern i think those
are all like very short-term
you know if i get a scratch or something
it'll heal in a week if i blow out my
knees i'm done running forever so i will
trade
the short term for the long term any
time but even then yeah you know
this again to my wife's chagrin
your feet get tough right and uh cows
okay yeah
i can run over almost anything now
i mean what uh maybe can you talk about
is there a hint like is there tips
or tricks that you have uh suggestions
about
like if i wanted to try it you know
there is a good book
actually uh there's probably more good
books since i read them
but uh ken bob barefoot ken bob saxton
um he's an interesting guy but i think
his book
captured uh the right way to describe
running barefoot running to somebody
better than any other i've seen
so you run pretty good distances
and you bike and is is there um
you know if we talk about bucket list
items is there something crazy on your
bucket list
athletically that you hope to do one day
i mean my commute is already a little
crazy um what are we talking about here
what what uh what distance are we
talking about well i live about 12 miles
from mit
but you can find lots of different ways
to get there so i mean i've run
there for a long many years a bike there
um blaze
yeah but normally i would try to run in
and then bike home
bike in run home but you have run there
and back before
sure barefoot yeah uh yeah or with
minimal shoes or whatever that
12 12 times two yeah okay
it became kind of a game of how can i
get to work i've
rollerbladed i've done all kinds of
weird stuff but my favorite one these
days is i've been taking the charles
river to work
so i can put in a little robot
not so far from my house but the charles
river takes a long way to get to mit so
um i can spend a long time getting there
and it's you know it's not about
i don't know it's just about uh
i've had people ask me how can you
justify taking that time
uh but for me it's just a magical time
to think to compress decompress
um you know especially i'll wake up do a
lot of work in the morning and then
i kind of have to just let that settle
before i'm ready for all my meetings and
then
on the way home it's a great time to
sort of let that settle
so you you lead a like a a large
group of people i mean you're
is there days where you're like oh [ __ ]
i gotta get to work in an hour
like i i mean uh
is is there is there a tension there
where and like if we look at the grand
scheme of things just like you said long
term that meeting probably doesn't
matter like you can always say
i'll just i'll run and let the meeting
happen how it happens
like what uh how do you
that zen how do you uh what do you do
with that tension
between the real world saying urgently
you need to be there
this is important everything is melting
down
how we're going to fix this robot
there's this uh
critical meeting and then there's this
the design beauty of just
running the simplicity of it you along
with nature
what do you do with that i would say i'm
not a fast runner particularly
probably my fastest splits ever was when
i had to get to daycare on time because
they were going to charge me
you know some some dollar per minute
that i was late uh
i've run some fast splits to daycare
but that those times are passed now um
i think work you can find a work-life
balance in that way
i think you just have to um i think i am
better at work
because i take time to think on the way
in so i plan my day around it um
and i i rarely feel that those are
really in
at odds so what the bucket list item
if we're talking 12 times two
we're approaching a marathon
what have you run an ultra marathon
before do you do races is there what's
uh
to win not to uh
i'm not gonna like take a dinghy across
the atlantic or something if that's what
you want but uh
but if someone does and wants to write a
book i would totally read it because i'm
a sucker for that kind of thing
no i do have some fun things that i will
try you know i like to
when i travel i almost always bike to
logan airport and fold up a little
folding bike on and then take it with me
and bike to wherever i'm going and
i've it's taken me or i'll take a
stand-up paddleboard these days
on the airplane and then i'll try to
paddle around where i'm going or
whatever and i've done some
crazy things but um but not for the
you know i've i now talk i don't know if
you know who david goggins is by any
chance
not well but yeah but i i talk to him
now every day so he's the person
who made me uh do this stupid challenge
so he he's insane and he does things for
the purpose
in in the best kind of way he does
things
like for the explicit purpose of
suffering
like he picks the thing that like
whatever he thinks he can do he does
more uh so is that do you have
that thing in you or you uh i think it's
become the opposite
it's uh so you're like that dynamical
system that the walker the efficient
uh yeah it's uh leave no
pain right you should end feeling better
than you started
okay but um it's mostly i think
and kovit has tested this because i've
lost my commute
i think i'm perfectly happy walking
around
around town with my wife and kids if
they could get them to go
and it's more about just getting outside
and getting away from the keyboard for
some time just to let things compress
you